ciao ragazzi sappiamo tutti che cosa sta
succedendo in questo periodo ci è stato
chiesto di rimanere il più possibile a
casa io l'unica cosa che posso fare
l'eposizione oggi sono un medico non
salgo vite purtroppo avrebbe tutte
scegliere non è carriera migliore ma se
tenervi compagnia in questi giorni di
quarantena per questo che ho deciso di
mostrarvi insieme agli altri ragazzi del
team che cosa faremo in questi giorni mi
chiedo già accusa se non ci sarà un vero
e proprio senso logico i fatti che
vedrete potrebbero essere un pochino
mischiati a livello temporale a volte
metteremo delle storie che ci fanno
ridere su instagram ma soprattutto io
sopra una felpa da sotto sono ancora
nudo aperto sito di fare il bagno è
questo qui semplicemente un telo e
adesso toglierò oggi ho deciso di
volontari questa giornata per suggerire
delle attività da poter fare come nella
solitudine di casa propria a cucinare
mio caso è che una minaccia comunque
devo riuscire a fare l'uomo in camicia
oggi il momento della verità facciamo il
vortice prendiamo l'uovo e buttiamo l'ok
al centro tre minuti ma ma che è
intervenuto un uomo al tegame e guardate
muschio ma che io dopo quello in bagno
gira gira gira gira versa al centro
sempre in allerta mi sono reso conto di
non avere il pane e quindi sto usando
dei cornetti gli integrali prese un po
di nome come sarà in momenti non un'arte
volte le sincera io e mister wilson non
ce la stiamo passando per anche bene
diciamo che agisce un pochettino
battendo tra l'altro anche passando un
po il vergognoso comunque essere una
coppia di fidanzati giovani e in
quarantena insomma non è così semplice e
poi lui è una persona molto attiva in
genere nella sua vita perché pratica
retti quindi però abbiamo avuto una
grande idea e speriamo in realtà che
questo esperimento non ci conduca alla
morte certa
vi faccio vedere la grande
e a ragazzi non è un savall e può
sembrare un capitolo a parte che non lo
è
ecco qui il mio fidanzato sempre più
attonito punteremo il palo a casa
un'altra cosa potremmo fare a casa è un
caso lamentiamo spesso al fatto che ci
sia sempre qualcosa da fare che non
abbiamo mai un tempo per noi stessi
arriva una pandemia e vogliamo fare
dawson's creek che problemi abbiamo
state viene a casa non fanno un cazzo se
volete fare qualcosa non fate un ca
tassi davvero se potete non uscite
quello che fai l'aperitivo fatelo a caso
si fa così è davvero 32 rigiro in una
prima detto rito 28 28 stimato o sin
alla duramente nel frattempo che
facciamo una scala volendo l'altro
quando finisce di periodo e di uscire di
casa che sembro due figli attraverso
lavoro hanno perso fesso diventato padre
ragazzi ma è tanto difficile restare a
casa cioè nel senso le mie giornate sono
rimasti invariati ecco il problema era
che toccavo uscì di casa per debellare
il contagio da quanti giorni è iniziata
la quarantena vent'anni su per giù io ma
la sta passando bene
in realtà ci posso capire che per molti
di voi possa essere un tragico il fatto
di rimanere a casa ecco però ci stanno
un sacco di modi per investire il
proprio tempo a casa non vedete potete
pure fa casino anche se c'è lady vicini
a casa perché tanto il fatto detto virus
nessuno s'azzarda a dio guarda cioè
potresti fa che ha anzi si divertiranno
pure secondo me rai oggi
stanotte ho capito una cosa ho capito
che il compito di noi artisti è quello
di rendere il nostro lavoro ha meno
difficile questo momento e così farò
[Musica]
uscire
bisogna i ricchi di ioni pronti i
[ __ ] come suggerì rotto i [ __ ]
[Musica]
questo percorso bellissimo scusatemi
spicca la sedia questo è un pezzo
bellissimo mare la piena di vita datemi
la possibilità che cazzo verso
supermercato se poi tu non sai nemmeno
cucinare
come va questa quarantena ma ancora
sostenibile lo sta impazzendo sono
ancora poi con la vostra stupida
presenza fissa come va la popolana era
una bomba è felice per contentissima non
so se ce la farò
datemi le vostre forze agio come va
questa quadra terra è stanco della
quarantena e meghni oppure affrontata
manda in campo del caso ma come pasta
quarantena sempre se c'è uno se mi stavo
andando i matti sono tutte quelle
persone ti dicono ma da massimo in
famiglia siamo fra amici fatti pare che
succede qualcosa se avete ragione perché
proprio anche a livello scientifico è
detto che il coronavirus si attacca
solamente tra sconosciuti a tutte quelle
braccini avete presente perché lui ogni
volta appena vede una nuova oh oh oh
fermo fermo un secondo controllano va su
facebook proprio subito amici amici in
comune qualcosa
lui comunque mi sembra brutto anche
prende la mamma lui proprio aspetta che
esci o che ti han forno wii a quel punto
rompe coi ragazzi mister wilson ed io
abbiamo evidentemente fatta a montare il
palo che se non gli ho fatto vedere
tutti quanti passaggi quello che vi dico
cerchiamo di reggere botta re gatto che
insieme è chiaro ragazzi che pesi a
tutti quanti noi non mi faccio il
discorso che sta i corsi o meglio che
stanno girando adesso sui vari social
tutto meraviglioso momento per
incontrarmi con me stesso io
tendenzialmente l'esame di coscienza lo
faccio ogni giorno della mia vita a
prescindere dalla pertinenze caretti e
però sono delle regole devono rispettare
vani tutti quanti anche se vedi che
anche a me pesata morire nonostante
abbia il mio bambino che ho messo in
atto un pochino di suggerimenti per
l'uovo in camicia hai guardato come
venuto
va fatto ogni tanto fa stare meglio
allora ragazzi buongiorno e la notte ha
portato consiglio non dite proprio non
dire non voglio sentire che non penso a
voi una cosa che mi manca tanto non
pensavo che l'avrei mai detto perché ho
la stessa socievolezza di satellite che
mi sarebbe mancato tantissimo il
contatto con le persone oggi ho trovato
un medico un metodo e questo metodo si
chiama salone di bellezza autre body
experience avrete bisogno di carta e
scotch
io in questo caso vedete ho preso nella
carte o scocciato a mano in questo non
la sento più io adesso non hanno quindi
cosa faccio prende una mano la infilo e
una e ora chiudo gli occhi e sento il
calore di un altra persona perché non ho
sensibilità bellissimo grazie mille
chi si va al mare e gambe mentre gli
stock a caldo lo sotto tutti i gomiti
appena gli altri medica di postare
dentro che si sensazione tanto va
superato dall estate quindi facciamolo
non esce niente da me era non si può
fare in questa fase
questo stallo dovuto mettere gli altri
quindi la vuoi farlo deve tutto a posto
politicante piacevole perché si apre
qualsiasi porta in questo gioco c'è
qualcosa che ci sfugge però basta io col
capo che ciò che questo gioco basta
spengo tutto addio playstation ciao e
buonanotte niente resident evil colpo
arrow questo gioco
terribile non pensavo che avrei mai
detto questa cosa ma mio fratello
gabriele ha creato una cosa è sicura
programma fisico da covip
la mia proposta è la seguente domani al
17 allenamento
ognuno a casa propria in diretta con
gabriele che ci fa da istruttore chi se
la colla so che la 49 mi sta aiutando
tantissimo a livello psicologico ma mi è
venuta in mente un'idea geniale di una
sfida che molto molto carina si chiama
espressioni persone devono stare con la
faccio assolutamente così e solo con le
mani creare un espressione faccio un
esempio un sorriso di gioia
credo in realtà io non avevo messo
niente oppure stupore e rare compagnia
serata tutti insieme raggiungendo
metello così alto di solitudine che per
me è una serata con gli amici e tipo
capo della di pizza non stai quali
all'inferno e tipo una serata a casa
fondamenti va di scena un'allegoria
funesta in questo momento muratore
tantissimi materializza nel tuo scritto
durante la notte è nonna come va la
quarantena
[Musica]
pesano anche a me con tutto che a me
piace stare a casa
c'è chi come ti senti una cosa proibita
genera appetito così si dice vuoi dare
un consiglio a chi ci segue da casa di
stare tranquilli e di pregare
ci sono delle rose a rifanno alla
televisione delle mense anche per
supplire quello che durante la settimana
abbiamo sempre avuto
ciao a tutti poi procede fatelo
quarantena se fa questi effetti
tracciata preoccupati e si chiama
qualcuno c'è tanto vedo solo
videochiamate con gente ha detto muti
sarà il nuovo di turno
che non vedo da sei giorni pare che non
vedo da sei anni come ti senti in questo
momento di riflessione è veramente
doveri ci sono due tre giorni che non
gioco alla play non vedo serie simile
aggiornato non c'è tempo prima di niente
ci manca un quarantena uno tra tempo
jesi ma promessi partorito o una domanda
per tutti quanti sono sul balcone di
casa mia ma voi non sentire l'aria tipo
più pulita non sto crescendo sul motto
io sto a casa
passo la giornata a leggere guardare
film per niente mi sto laureando tra
quattro mura
perché continuo a sentirmi un fallito
terzo giorno di 40 no poi ripreso ancora
raga non bisognerebbe so ancora questo
allenamento
va bene tutto pezzo però c'è non vi
posso fare devo mister uscendo dei
muscoli guarda questa nostra restano
tanto questa cosa se mi ha covato ecco
guardate semi accovaccia mingo bisco
sembra con gli addominali tosto leggendo
dei messaggi che sono coste quali con
mostrato i muscoli o costole come che
non alcuni un problema è una domanda da
fare
io sto cercando di dare il buon esempio
e non uscire di casa ma la situazione è
questa
più altre roba in balcone rispetto della
spazzatura tra parentesi
ottima la situazione a roma
niente raga è come se avesse appena
fatto una passeggiata saint tropez
io ho dovuto alla mancanza su su su ok
una cosa importantissima ogni volta che
uscite non fatevi prendere dal panico
non fatevi prendere il panico
soprattutto pulite il cellulare pulite
il cellulare e porta che fa che ho fatto
una chiamata così lunga forse 14 anni
mica 14 anni mi sentivo piano i dubbi un
po fallito e non è cambiato un camion
uno scherzo sempre però in realtà sono
già che appunto difficili per me
volevo regalarvi questa cover nella
speranza che possa parlarvi come mi ha
parlato forse in questo temporale devo
ringraziare veramente questo video di
quarantena perché sto riscoprendo la mia
passione per la musica si si si
un motivo in più per odiare il corona
[Musica]
discreta tiro fuori la scritta di tutto
allora ragazzi siamo arrivati all
non so come si chiama un momento delle
luci perizia tecnica
io temo di dovermi di sociale da questo
gesto non luce che al telefono indotta
casinò così satellite ci vedrà giusta
ciao visse ros che viene fatto questa
cosa ah infatti ne dissocio accendi la
luce per un segno di solidarietà perché
lo facciamo 40 è la spiegazione a tutto
questo si quale sono tre giorni di
seguito che ci sono degli appuntamenti
di vivere anche questa solidarietà ormai
il mio modo per comunicare vicino charge
etica ciao era per la settimana che
dovete quella faccia nuova vi saluto
ragazzi è stato bello eliminare la
termine siano a voi ragazzi l'ho mai
favore siamo giocata anche ai miei
vicini e presa questa specie di
dermatite da concerto per cui ci stanno
gli orari in cui ci si affaccia al
balcone e sembra la finale del mondiale
si canta l'inno a un certo punto si
rispolverano tutte quante canzoni
terribili io sono sempre rimasto a casa
c'è un profilo te pare non faccio queste
cose prima
fatto sta che stasera ha messo in piedi
una playlist ma di quelle che gli
strappano l'anima non so perché non so
perché lo mettano raffaella carrà ma
mettano capitolo battisti battisti e
quindi mi sono un po commosso al balcone
e m'è preso una botta di moto ho detto
mo vado a prendere le casse che tengono
in cantina tipo da un anno e cerco
almeno di rendermi utile per il vicinato
ho creato una console di quelle
devastanti
domani o dopo aver fatto l'allenamento
dovrò spingere verso il balcone re
sparare musica bomba che stasera per
provarlo fatto un giro di falsi questi
file notte mi sono stati chiesti dal
gruppo di vicini perché io faccio parte
pure il gruppo origini e non mi sono
mancate ma che non lo so questo
coronavirus unisce le persone mi rende
meno misantropo non lo so io parlerei
pure
costituiti forte interazione con
qualcuno o per motivi di copyright non
posso farvi sentire quello che stavo
riproducendo però da un'idea ambler snam
nena martina
del prof
gli episodi passati un po ma adesso io
adesso non abbiamo chiesto un po di
italiano e 21 e play off via per quello
che faccio indovinare via adesso
riposati perché ti prende un colpo ma la
famiglia non mi sento calmarlo fisco